the tom green show on mtv i've said this
so many times like i literally
sat there and and recorded every episode
of the tom green show and was so
careful when the commercial break
started i would hit pause on my vcr
to in real time edit out the commercial
breaks and then hit record again when
the commercial break was over
i had the whole library of the tom green
show and i just loved it
so much man i remember when we filmed
jackass for the first time
uh like i shared a room with our line
producer
who who told me that i was like what
other shows have you done he said i
worked on the tom green show and all of
a sudden i just had this
reverence for this this producer that
tripper
it was it was tripp did the tom green
show
tripp did the tom green chair and i just
thought that was so cool man
and if you think so there was the you
know the the godfather of the
of the you know podcasting wow that the
podcasting came after but
yeah what do you call that what that
mean hidden camera you can't say
the hidden camera because like candid
camera had been around for so long but
like
that man on the street gag that just
weird
you know like there's definitely and
i've always really looked up to people
who can
make footage that's that's compelling
and that's that's
awesome without like doing anything uh
you know dangerous or or destructive or
you know like or super gross and puke
everywhere like
it was well we got pretty gross but yeah
painting your parents house plaid or or
or paying their car the [ __ ] yeah yeah
you know i mean it's interesting
right like because we were both
skateboarders and i loved skateboarding
as a kid
and so you know for me like when i was a
kid
i would watch like palo peralta videos
you know like i was watching like it was
it was future primitive was the first
one that i saw
that was like where i remember seeing
video that didn't look like it was made
by you know nbc or something you know it
was like stacy peralta's
future primitive and they were going you
know they were cruising around
new york city and jumping off like the
back of
you know vans and lance mountain would
like wipe out like
flip around on the ground and [ __ ] and
everyone was like on the street real
people reacting and i was looking at
that going like
man like that's like raw real
like energy that i've never seen on
television before
except for maybe maybe a little bit of
david letterman was doing stuff like
where he'd go in the street
but everything else was so controlled so
so uh you know kind of uh rehearsed and
everything so
but you know we kind of grew up at that
same time where it's like
you know all of a sudden we had we could
get a video camera right like we didn't
get a video camera before and
all of a sudden you could go out and
make sort of gorilla
gonzo kind of amateur tv
which you know maybe it wasn't as
perfectly shot or perfectly
produced but the fact that it was so raw
and nobody ever like
when people looked at you when you went
up to someone on the street they didn't
think that you were from the tv station
because you weren't
and so they'd kind of react real and it
was just the right time you know like we
just sort of
you know we were both there at that time
when all of a sudden like
everything changed we started filming
stuff
no youtube nobody watching it ever seen
anything like that before
and sometimes i kind of like feel like
man like
i don't think people today young people
today i don't think they can kind of
quite grasp
how crazy it was when when our [ __ ] came
on tv
back in the early 2000s or 90s because
like
nobody had seen it before now like you
can put stuff like that out now and you
can do stuff like that now but they're
comparing it to all the stuff they see
we're overwhelmed by all this weird
video
it doesn't have that impact that it had
back together i'm so fat there's so much
here and i'm so fascinated by it because
i think what made it so special was that
at that time when you and i started
filming our stuff
the video camera was still not yet
really
a household item you know it was like
pretty you know not
not most households had a video camera
and it was skateboarders who were the
first to
the first to really we had such a leg up
in video production
skateboarders because our whole culture
of skateboarding was about
trying to get sponsored so you had to
videotape your skateboarding in order to
try to get sponsors
and there was never another activity
that lent itself to making videos
like say for example if you were a
tennis player then you want to get
sponsored then
when you win tournaments you know check
out my tennis video
there was no other thing like there was
no other thing like skateboarders that
really
like first came to the video camera we
got so far ahead of everybody else
with the video camera and at a time when
it wasn't a household item
and you're absolutely right plus when
our stuff came out on mtv
still the average person didn't have a
video camera let alone in their pocket
and the media wasn't so fragmented to
where there was like i mean sure there
was there was cable tv and there was
network tv
but when when our stuff came out there
was no such thing as playing
videos on the internet i mean
it was like weber vision at tom in tom
green's living room was like
really the first streaming video i think
right yeah i got i've got so much
footage of us i've got it all on
drives and on tapes and stuff like i
mean uh don't worry i'll i'll
i'll i'll let you see it before i don't
i don't i don't i don't mind one bit tom
i don't mind one bit
and it was it was publicly it got pretty
crazy though man like i remember it was
it was like
you know that was i mean that was kind
of exciting because
you know when i was doing the web show
here in this room right like this
that's that's where we were sitting
right there you're sitting where the
bleachers were
yeah i'm right i'm right where the
bleachers were at bleachers in my living
room
for what so amazing audience
and it was just like stevo would bring
his friends i'd have my friends and
people would just sort of sit here and
watch and get a little studio audience
you know that's great
there was like a lot of like big time
people in there like
we had really great hours and hours in a
row with carson daly i remember that
fondly dr jews i mean there were some
some
you know you had a lot of uh really
famous people in there
yeah it was it was weird because like
you know it felt a little bit like you
know when i started my show
you know on public access we were kind
of doing something that
was kind of unique right because the
video camera
was sort of a you know shooting with i
didn't actually have a video camera i
had to go pop
volunteer at the public access station
so they'd lend me their video camera you
know nice i didn't have any money i had
no money you know i was like
so broke i was worked at dairy queen
uh you know i'd make a hundred bucks a
week i'd spend it all on a new
skateboard deck or
you know a drum machine or save up for a
thing i'd never had any money for a
video camera video cameras for like two
thousand dollars or something like that
you know
so uh yeah but like then when we did the
webo vision that was like
that was kind of later you know it's
it's weird like how that seems like a
long time ago now because it doesn't
like to me that always feels like
you know it was like that was after my
show on mtv
but it was but it's now a long time ago
which is scary because that means like
we're really [ __ ] old now is that
what that means yeah
guess what i have the number 30 ranked
hot sauce on all of
amazon it's called stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
yeah yeah
dude